i learned so many lessons from dance
moms and
even though like it still does have like
a negative kind of effect on me i
and i would never change anything
because it's made me the person who i
am today when you think of nia stu's
career what is the ultimate
goal i really want to be like an ego is
there anybody special in your life right
now
i always say i'm like my dms are open if
anyone wants to slide in
if you know anything about me you know
that dance is my life
i want to meet some amazing people who
happen to have disabilities who love
dance just as much as i do
congratulations your new show danced
with mia
tell us everything about it what's the
concept yes
okay so i'm so excited to share so dance
with mia it's a facebook watch show
but with also brat tv so i'm so excited
to be working
with those companies but also it's my
first ep
role i'm executive producer on it which
is so exciting
i'm highlighting dancers who are just
incredible
highlighting like the ableism that they
face in the dance world and in the
industry
because we're focusing on dancers who
are disabled
what has been the most rewarding part
about doing this show
and what has been the most fun the most
fun part of the show
would be dancing with them because i
don't get to perform as much anymore
like dance wise
so it was amazing to do like these
little music videos with them at the end
of each episode
it was like a full-on music video
and it felt just good to be dancing
again since i don't get to
dance as often anymore no knowing you
i knew this wasn't going to be a small
production it was going to be a no
production full wardrobe full makeup
full hair wow it's sick isn't it
what i learned the most about myself is
first of all i need to be way more
confident these dancers
are literally amazing and they have
so much stage presence and confidence
and
i learned a lot of that from them i
watched you do a burlesque routine on
tick-tock girl you embody
confidence in my eyes thank you
[Music]
i also have to commend you i think it's
so wonderful
that you're a full-time student at ucla
getting your education on top of an
incredible career
so my first question is how is college
going
oh my gosh it's going great it's all
online right now this is my
finals week actually so it's a busy week
um lots of papers and projects to turn
in
but it's been great so far and i'm
actually really fortunate that
it was online this year because i was
able to work while i was in school which
was a challenge but we did it you've got
this amazing career
and now you just tacked on a full-time
course load at ucla
how is it managing everything you know
sometimes it can be
really stressful like not even gonna lie
it's a
it's a lot of pressure sometimes
and i i think what helps me the most is
like having my family like
just there with everything going on like
having people who can encourage me
whenever i'm like i just can't do this
and my mom's like you can do this my
my dad's like you can do this my friends
they're like we believe in you so like i
have a whole team behind me like i
couldn't do this by myself
so what is it you're studying at ucla
what are you majoring in
i'm an american literature major i do
love to write and i think that
with acting and i hope hopefully one day
i can
start writing my stuff and um also music
wise as well like i just love writing
and i think it's going to help me
a lot in the writing realm i know you're
so busy with your career and everything
you've got going on
acting singing dancing social media star
now you're a spin
when you think of when you think of nia
stu's career
what is the ultimate goal how do you
want that to look
i'm a performer and i love to help
people so whatever that
is whatever that is
i think that will just make me the
happiest one of my biggest goals which
seems like so huge but i really want to
be like an egot right
one day because i love every aspect i
want
i want the emmy i want i want the grammy
i want the oscar i want the tony or not
even
getting all those things but being able
to do all of those things
i have to tell you every time you post a
tick tock
that's about your dating life or about
relationships or romances
they absolutely crack me up i don't know
i really don't know
is there anybody special in your life
right now you know what's so funny that
you ask me this right now so
i'm i was doing something on my
instagram today where it's like asking a
question or something and someone was
like how long have you and your
boyfriend been together and i was like
i literally don't have a boyfriend i was
like i don't know where you guys are
getting this information from
i'm like whoever says i have a boyfriend
please show him to me
my love life is in shambles but it's
actually not i just don't
shampoo dating right now is so hard it
is
so hard what is so hard finding a guy
who is okay with like being long
distance-ish because whether i'm in
pittsburgh
or l.a um
it's still going to be long distance
because i go back and forth all the time
another thing as well i work a lot and
i'm a very independent person
and i don't necessarily need anyone so i
think the fact that i don't like
need another person in my life
i think might be like oh like she's too
independent for me and i'm like nah like
no the right person
they'll be the icing on your cake if
someone can add to my happiness that's
amazing
but um having someone in my life won't
necessarily make me happy because i'm
already happy but it will add to my
happiness
so i always say i'm like my dm's are
open if anyone wants
to slide in i don't know if you know
this
but this july marks 10 years
since the very first premiere of dance
moms
mia has a lot of confidence and i think
mia has a lot of ability and talent
my goal for nia this year is really
funnier to grow as a dancer
think back on the last 10 years what
comes to mind
most of my life i have been on a tv show
um
and i guess like what really like comes
to mind is like
the girls honestly like just spending
time with them and my mom
i am still really close to a lot of like
the og girls
and um i'm still really close to my mom
we met you at age
10 you're now a beautiful young woman
what was it like
growing up so young in front of the
world
oh crazy i mean i grew up so fast you
know
not only just being in the dance
competition world but being on a reality
tv show as well
helps you grow up a time i learned so
many
lessons from dance moms and um even
though like
it still does have like a negative kind
of effect on me i and i would never
change anything because
it's made me the person who i am today
even though it was really challenging
and i don't
some and sometimes i don't have the best
things to say about it
but i do have to always give them credit
for
just like getting me to the place where
i am today
do you ever feel like it took part of
your childhood away or do you ever wish
maybe
that you could have pumped the brakes or
maybe that you had taken a step back at
a certain point
it took away a little bit from my
childhood but i think it's just like a
different childhood you know like
i wouldn't say i didn't have no
childhood because i did have this
childhood it was just different from
everyone else's and that was my
normal childhood and we still had fun
like going to
traveling to different places and
everything and getting to experience
that with my mom like
who gets to do that and get to do it
with
one of my family members like my mom
who's my my closest friend
let me ask you this because we spoke
with your mom when she launched her
podcast a couple months ago
yes and we asked her this question and
she she had a really thoughtful response
but i felt like
the girls were always kind of fighting
their way into
you know that was a lot of your story
lines saying you know we're really loyal
we've stuck around
uh why did you stick around for so long
i think some people don't
say we're understand to leave i don't
want anyone in my children's lives to
dictate to them
you leave because i'm forcing you out or
because you're not wanted
you have value you have worth you love
and you're passionate about your craft
no one gets to tell you
that you are not wanted and you have to
leave i think that's a great question
um i think the thing that stands out the
most from this question
is on the show i felt like i was never
wanted
from day one never wanted but me
being the person that i am i don't let
people
see me fail or like get the best of me
you know like i'm like
just because someone doesn't just
because people or someone doesn't want
me here that makes me want to stay even
more
so honestly that was the incentive like
i didn't want anyone making me out to be
inferior because i'm not also because i
was the only blocker on the show i
wasn't about to like
quit in you know somebody say oh
you know like the only black girl on the
show wasn't good or any no
like i'm gonna stay like i deserve to be
here just as much as everyone else
at times like it did like i got knocked
down like really
like really badly and you know sometimes
i would consider like do i really want
to do this and then i think about it i'm
like no like i've
made it this far like why would i why
would i stop now
you obviously have a huge social media
presence and you have a youtube page
do you see the comments from your fans
about how
talented and brilliant and resilient and
beautiful you are
despite having negativity on the show
you really have such a positive platform
do you see your
fans you know praising you for those
reasons thank you
i i do i read those comments and
it it makes me feel like i'm doing
something right you know
um i think that literally like i said
before like all i want to do is just
like make other people happy and
although you can't make everyone happy
i'm going to try my best
i want to ask you about one of your tick
tocks that went viral
[Music]
why did you feel compelled to share that
story even if it was in a lighthearted
way on tick tock
i saw like i think jojo and kenzie did
it before and i was like this is funny i
was like this is funny
people nowadays whenever they think that
they can really get under my skin i was
like do you understand that like you
it would take a lot for you to be able
to like break me down and to like
actually like be hurt by like something
that you said you put in the caption
you survived the ultimate bully if your
former dance instructor
is watching this interview do you have
any sort of a message for her do you
guys keep in contact
you know i don't keep in contact with
her at all um
but i do just want to say like honestly
like
i'm a person of love i hope that she's
healed i hope that she's doing well i
hope that she's living her best life
if there was an opportunity to do a
reunion all of you
oh geez and abby and the moms
first of all are there conversations
about ever doing something like that no
no okay would you ever be interested is
that an idea that you would ever want to
revisit
no absolutely maybe with the girls i do
something with just the girls but like
adding the moms
and like the dance teachers back into it
like that just
does not seem like fun at all i would do
anything for the girls like literally i
and i truly do mean that i just saw
chloe the other day actually
i took her out for a birthday dinner so
i was so excited
to see her and i see like maddie and
kenzie do not live far from me in l.a
and brooke was living in la for a little
so i'd see her whenever
so it was all yeah so like i keep in
contact with them 10 years of dance moms
i'm hoping that you can pick a moment
that you really
love and you're so glad that you have it
on camera to revisit and enjoy
and the one moment that makes you cringe
and you wish either never happened or
that you know maybe the cameras weren't
there for
shangela uh
aka laquifa i am so happy to capture
that on camera because whenever she
strut into that room
like little baby nia was not ready for
her let's all welcome
la queefa
[Music]
and she was like why the creeper
what i mean wearing like a wolf mask on
ourselves while in a dance
like that was that was cringy i'm like i
hope like my future husband does not
see this also like we did like a seven
dwarves dance and like
this is gonna be so tmi but like like
our little like
hats we had we put like like pads like
in our hats to make it like stand up
like
just like why why what was the need for
all of this like